vendredi 26 octobre 2012 ce jour de fête
dans la communauté musulmane de censure
l'école fontenay-le-fleury c'est l'aïd
el kébir jour où l'on commémore la
soumission d'abraham à dieu mais malgré
l'ambiance de fête les mines sont
soucieuses le projet de construction
d'une mosquée et d'un centre culturel
islamique tournon à l'enduro bordeaux 2e
belle surtout sur la commune de saint
cyr c'est nécessaire d'avoir un lieu de
culte comme mosquée à ce moment là on
attendait ça fait dix ans on attend non
seulement il est nécessaire mais il est
indispensable car nous avons beaucoup de
familles de saint cyr et de fontenay qui
sont obligés d'aller dans les mosquées
avoisinantes
aujourd'hui les familles sont dispersés
dans en tout ces mosquées la une est
vraiment triste
elles ne sont pas réunies dans un seul
lieu
c'est ce terrain qui a été retenue par
les différentes parties problème il est
situé à la fois sur les communes de
saint cyr l'école et de
fontenay-le-fleury le foncier appartient
à la mairie de fontenay mais pour
l'exploiter il faudrait modifier le plan
local d'urbanisme de saint cyr hier soir
j'ai eu monsieur le maire monsieur
bernard de bain au téléphone il m'a dit
qu'il n'était pas contre de ce projet
mais qu'il fallait refaire revoir le
paie lui une consultation publique devra
donc être organisées avant toute
modification du pmu c'est qui peut
prendre du temps
à cela s'ajoute l'échéance électorale je
pense que la période avant 2014 est une
période où naturellement on ne va pas
lancer un projet qui ferait qui se
raccrocherait à de la politique
politicienne mais certainement pas sur
le fond
les musulmans qui ont pour l'instant
collecter un cinquième de la somme
nécessaire à construction du bâtiment
espèrent être dans les murs d'ici trois
ans le bâtiment coûte en totalité un
million et demi d'euros
le lieu de culte s'adresserait aux 1200
familles musulmanes de saint cyr
fontenay et bois d'arcy soit 4000
fidèles
le centre socioculturel serait quant à
elle ouvert au grand public et
proposerait des cours de civilisation et
d'arabes une bibliothèque ainsi que du
soutien scolaire